[Musica]
[Applauso]
protestiamo che dite ciao a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono poi le oggi siamo appunto sul
nuovo gameplay grazie dell'abbonato
abbiamo sul gameplay finalmente della
playstation 5 mi voglio scusare al volo
perché ieri non sono riuscito a
pubblicarlo perché sarebbe dovuto uscire
ieri dopo l'unboxing questo ragazzi
perché è talmente top secret tutto ciò
che circonda la playstation
la ps5 che non posso far vedere
determinate cose e nel video di oggi ho
dovuto tagliare un sacco di roba che ho
registrato come la schermata di avvio
della della playstation 5 non la posso
far vedere quindi non la vedrete i primi
passi che nuovo sul gioco che non posso
farvi vedere posso farvi vedere solo un
determinato livello e quindi ragazzi
vedrete un gameplay un po a metà però
molto carino secondo me prima di
cominciare dico sono una roba al volo il
controller della playstation 5 a una
feature nuova che il grilletto c'è
semplicemente a un certo punto si
irrigidiscono i tasti l2 e r2 e
schiacciarli diventa più diventa una
pistola di vento
non so spiegarvi e ste cose vabbè
comunque nel gioco vedrete che farò dirò
cose tipo mamma mia che figo non sto
diventando pazzo semplicemente sono i
grilletti che fanno resistenza un po
strano comunque gode temi il video
iscriviti al canale e come sempre
ragazzi buona visione
collins prince and drums ok è molto più
ampio di play.com quello vecchio ragazzi
questo player un gigantesco cioè
lunghissimo la giocare si mette un anno
e mezzo è proprio un gioco vero e cioè
all'interno della playstation finissimo
salve non vorrei interromperle
il relax però a lui non gliene frega
niente va bene
state calmi tutti perché io ho già
l'ansia di a cazzotti tutto bene se non
aiutato le monete servono a qualcosa di
sto gioco che non lo so non ho idea
questo l'hanno seppellito nella sabbia
sei veramente un filo già solo il play
come carinissimo ragazzi però dove devo
andare di qua ma succederà ganci penso
io
dove trai qua dentro io pensavo fosse
solo per testare joystick invece un
gioco vero
avete tutta la mia simpatia per la
paperella da bagno ragazzi non so se
posso cavalcarla semifinali
no però ci possa saltare sopra
tranquillamente ragazzi avete la piscina
ma crolla
ok
sono una rana a posso piegarmi a r2
amato nome ragazzi non vi so spiegare
che figata il grilletto
c'è il grilletto diventa rigido e magia
questa non lancerò mai più un joystick
dall'incazzatura no perché vi succede
perché il grilletto potrebbero spiegare
quindi non lo farò un metodi pati
giocherò a demon's souls come ultimo
gioco prima dell'uscita da abete 26
perché sennò non sfrutterei a dovere
questi biglietti yeah
no lo sforzo no è una è difficile
ragazzi non voleva prima volta che gioca
un videogioco è normale che mi metto a
fare le cose
tutto a posto raga tutto sotto controllo
non ho ben capito ma perché c'è un tizio
infilato dentro il giorno nero sono
morto a noi domanda domanda così
fratellini o che lo spaccare tutto nuovo
artefatto l'accessorio tiratore scelto
come si fa
ma brown sono un sito scusi cold spring
frozen pool la piscina ghiacciata
va bene non ho ben capito no no no non
mi rompere il card
bellissimo perché i peggiori anche coi
raggi laser è utile perché non lo voglia
sempre nella quasi tutti è un po troppo
ghiacciata st piscina se questo per
metterli in prove madonna dal vado coro
grazie non ho capito cosa sto fa niente
si levi dalle balle grazie
c'è gente che allora il problema non è
tanto la gente ma il freddo quando ero
piccola andavo in una piscina riscaldata
perché quelle normali mi danno fastidio
io io sono fatto per essere coccolato
nella vita perché spiega perché serve il
trofeo sono morto sono morto né non
stavo leggendo il trofeo scusami sono
adesso giustificato o tornato il primo
trofeo a me mancano tantissimi primo di
tantissimi altri poteri ha scritto dammi
la tua testa
grazie quindi ci sono un miliardo di
come si dice di trofei
dopo l'importante è veramente se io
gioco con la playstation in un posto
dove c'e dentro questa cosa succede
automaticamente nella foto jolo
spaccando tu no non voleva tornare lì
solo stupido
niente ragazzino la prima volta che
gioco mi sono lento nel capire le cose
sorry aiuto non l'ho preso quello non fa
niente salve ciao ragazzi come tutta po
grazie che esultate per me io vi picchio
su questo questo si chiama inizia volete
la k
carne comunque tutto ciò servirà una
crema questa questa è la pentola della
playstation questo casino è solo la
ventola pensate che casino mi piace un
sacco il persino che fa perché non ha un
senso
guarda il trofeo btb guarda al trofeo
che non ti piglio con procio problemi di
vista
salve ce l'abbiamo fatta è stato lungo
un'ora e mezza ma significhi bello a fa
vicino
ciao ragazzi stato affari video dovreste
lasciare a me però fa niente a cosa
serve straw casi circo il boss finale su
mettete quella è una plate re zio sarà
unisce la 2 3 1 hart fatto addirittura
ma perché ho trovato la playstation
questa va comunque ragazzi ormai e
museale pollici 12 anni mamma mia
ragazzi come vuole il tempo ero solo un
bambino adesso sono ancora un bambino
non la barba però fa niente spero
vivamente che vi sia piaciuto nel primo
unboxing insomma perché è un momento
epocale questo quadro a mio nipote
guarda nonno che spero che tu giochi
alla playstation 26 e tuo nonno giocava
aveste shaun 5 appena ci pensate che che
ero nipote se stai guardando questo
video
mammamia metti mi piace per favore anche
da vecchio andrò a gravare live spero
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi grazie
ancora sony grazie a tutti voi per
averlo visto lasciato mi piace se vi è
piaciuto fatemi sapere se volete altri
gameplay di playstation 5 quale i
commenti iscrivetevi al canale se non si
fanno gli scritti e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]